I nearly drowned once I was doing a
stunt in uh Bulgaria and I literally the
car went over the edge and I said before
they get on let me just do a little test
drive
so I'm in the truck there and I slam on
the brakes where I'm supposed to stop
nothing happens next thing you know I've
hit two cameramen they I literally
thought I killed him it was like a split
second later I'm going nine feet over
the edge of this concrete Jetty and I'm
going down towards the like the the
Black Sea thinking I've got to get out
of this so I'm trying to prize myself
from behind the wheel to get out the
window the windows are down the truck
hits the water the water just slams me
back and we just like sinking fast
straight to the bottom you know
eventually I you know come out the
surface and at that point Jimmy I mean
you really do understand who your
friends are so I'm looking around I look
out I said where's Sly and he's you know
stood on the side of the doctor with his
iPhone
Jason you knew the doll because I cut
the brake line are you crazy get wet no
no no no